inadmissible et je vous le dis les
réseaux sociaux c'est eux qui foutent la
merde sachez-le ils sont en train de
[__] une merde monstre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et quand quand la semaine dernière il y
a eu un boycotte TPMP croyez que c'est
pas un acte antisémite ça bien sûr vous
croyez quoi moi je vous le dis moi oui
oui je dis c'est un acte antisémite j'ai
vu des gens qui cherchaient les sociétés
où j'avais des des parts pour les
boycotter je je vais vous dire là il se
passe tout ce qu'il faut pas faire je
vais vous
dire on va on fait tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire et on est en train dealler
vers une dérive qu'on redoutait tous Je
va vous dire il y a même des artistes
qui nosent même plus venir sur le
plateau parce qu'ils disent on va me
demander mon avis sur le problème au
Proche Orient et cetera donc là on est
en train de tout mélanger et je vais
vous dire là nous et je pense la France
tous les
Français on est dans un pays
extraordinaire la France c'est un pays
exceptionnel et les Français sont
exceptionnels je suis désolé les
Français ils sont exceptionnels et les
Français ils ont fait qu'on puisse on a
pu vivre ici tous ici une vie incroyable
et aujourd'hui on est en train d'attiser
la haine de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
alors qu'au contraire tous les Français
on devrait être uni
pour que qu'on avance vers la paix ça
s'arrête je veux vous dire c'est pas
parce qu'on va le faire que ça va
arriver mais moi ce que j'aimerais au
lieu de voir des manifestations d'un
côté et de l'autre moi ce que j'aimerais
moi c'est voir des Français toutes les
confessions oui ouis avec un drapeau
israélien un drapeau palestinien et
qu'on puisse faire une marche voilà pour
la paix voilà la paix ici a défaut
d'être la paix là-bas en fait la paix
là-bas on y arrivera pas n en tout cas
nous à notre échelle on n arrivera pas
c'est pas nous qui allons faire la paix
là-bas mais par contre on peut faire la
guerre ici h et c'est ce qui se passe
actuellement donc faisons la paix ici
et quand je vois des des des des gens
sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont des comportements mais
inadmissibles j'étais pour les réseaux
sociaux maintenant je ne le suis plus
sachez-le je trouve qu'il y a une dérive
incroyable depuis ce conflit et je vous
dis aujourd'hui il faudrait qu'on fasse
tous une marche vraiment h tous ceux qui
veulent et le plus nombreux possible
parce que je pense qu'ici tous sur ce
plateau moi j'ai j'ai pas un pote juif
qui me dit je veux pas d'état
Palestiniens bah oui j'ai pas un pote
musulman qui me dit je veux la
destruction d'Israël et l'anéantissement
d'Israël ou donc alors où mes potes sont
tous cons
ou tous les gens que je côtoi sont des
abrutis ou bien les abrutis sont sur les
réseaux j'ai peut-être ma petite idée
je pense que les abrutis sont sur les
réseaux donc ne vous laissez pas
influencer par les réseaux c'est comme
la semaine dernière je vous dis aussi
ils ont fait une fausse rumeur comme
quoi l'émission était boycottée
l'émission va très bien mais ça c'est
pas le problème on s'en fout de
l'émission je vous dis on s'en fout ce
qu'on voit c'est la haine sur les
réseaux il faut pas qu'elle se déplace
dans la vie et dans la vie de tous les
jours moi je vous dis aujourd'hui avec
tous mes potes on n' pas changé et on
veut tous la même
chose ça se calme et qui est la paix on
est autant touché quand on voit des
familles massacrées par le Hamas que des
civils palestiniens et le petit qui qui
reconnaissait sa famille je vous le dis
le mec qui est pas qui est insensible à
ça c'est que c'est il a rien à faire ici
a rien à faire sur terre un mec qui soit
qui est insensible ou qui est pas
insensible ni à ce que j'ai dit sur les
familles israéliennes ni à ce que j'ai
dit sur ce petit je l'ai vu cette vidéo
je l' regardé une quinzaine de fois o Ce
Pier reconnaître sa famille tous les
corps de sa famille il a perdu toute sa
famille je vous le dis donc aujourd'hui
quand je vois des manifestations
proalestinienne grand plaisir je vois
des manifestations proisraéliennes avec
grand plaisir mais il faudrait aussi
qu'on fasse peut-être une manifestation
ici pour la paix en France parce que
c'est inadmissible ce que je vois sur
les réseaux et quand j'ai mes potes com
j'ai mes potes musulmans ou juifs qui me
disent cyil en ce moment c'est compliqué
de faire des plateaux ils ont peur de
venir en à parler à la télévision et
qu'ils ont même qui ont même peur de
dire je suis pour la paix parce que
quand ils disent qu'ils sont sur la paix
mes potes musulmans ils se font défoncer
mes potes juif il ils se font défoncer
aussi donc je vais vous dire quand on
arrive à ce point de rupture à un moment
faut dire STOP il faut arrêter il faut
dire on on arrête les conneries et on
arrête d'être influencé par 1000 abruti
sur les réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils
sont pas plus hein et il tweetent
beaucoup et ici je le
redis ici on fera on on sera on essaiera
toujours d'être le plus juste possible
et c'est ce qu'on essayer de faire
maintenant ce que je vois sur les
réseaux je vous dis c'est inadmissible
les mecs qui viennent nous menacer
devant le studio c'est inadmissible ça
ça doit plus arriver je vous dis ça doit
plus arriver parce que c'est pas la
bonne solution et je vous dis importe la
guerre ici ça règlera pas le confit
là-bas bien au contraire
en
revanche faire la paix être dans une
paix comme on a toujours été ici et dans
le dialogue et de se dire on mine de
rien on veut tous la même chose et ben
ça fera peut-être ça fera peut-être pas
la paix là-bas mais au moins ici les
choses se calmeront et on pourra voilà
arrêter d'écouter des abrutis sur les
réseaux sociaux qui font passer des
messages de haine et qui font
qu'aujourd'hui je vous dis c'est
insupportable d'aller sur les réseaux
sociaux moi j'y vais pas du tout donc
vous pouvez continuer à m'insulter je
m'en fous total les réseaux sociaux j'y
vais jamais donc continuez à m'insulter
je vois je suis en hashtag ce soir je
vais être encore en têté hein mais je
m'en fous total hein Anouna entêté j'ai
l'habitude je pense que je suis le mec
le plus entêté de France donc continuez
mais vous feriez mieux de faire une
marche tous ensemble je vous le dis avec
un drapeau israélien et un drapeau
palestinien et je pense que ça fera
beaucoup plus avancer le chose que vos
conneries sur les réseaux et les
insultes et les menaces et cetera
d'accord arrêtez de menacer hein il vous
dis arrêtez de menacer arrêtez de faire
les malins sur les réseaux sociaux
arrêtez tout ça pensez plutôt à une paix
durable et peut-être ici et et ne
mélangez pas tout je vous dis personne
les gars et arrêtez de faire croire que
vous connaissez sur le conflit sur les
bouts des doigts et vous connaissez
exactement la situation la seule chose
qu'on veut tous c'est un État
palestinien un état israélien souverain
pour les deux aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est tout ce que tout le monde veut
mais quand je vois des abrutis qui
appellent à la destruction quand je vois
morts aux Arabes surtout Twitter ou mort
au Juif je vous dis ces gars-là pour moi
c'est inadmissible qu'ils sont encore
sur les réseaux sociaux doit avoir leur
adresse alleer les chercher et je peux
vous dire moi ils vont passer 3 jours
euh en cellule ils vont comprendre ce
que c'est je vais vous dire ou peut-être
même pas 3 jours 3 mois parce que c'est
beaucoup plus qu'il faut un mec qui dit
mort aux Arabes ou Mor au juif pour moi
il prend un an de tô ferme voilà je vous
le dis c'est c'est aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça donc ça je ça je veux pas le
voir moi sur les réseaux quand je vais
sur les réseau tous les matins et que je
vois ce genre de message je vous dis
j'ai qu'une envie c'est de me dire il
faut arrêter ces réseaux de de merde qui
font qui ne qui ne vraiment qui ne
diffusent que de la
haine sourire de la situation Manon qui
a filmé cette fameuse vidéo est avec
nous ce soir il va tout nous expliquer
c'est fou parce que Manon aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parlait que d'elle
cette personne qu'on voit et c'est vrai
que sur les réseaux on dit oui pourquoi
elle rigole et cetera elle voudrait
s'expliquer aussi ce soir Manon regardez
des images si vous n'avez pas vu ces
images sachez que c'était dans le métro
parisien aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est
c'est aujourd'hui c'était aujourd'hui
dans le métro parisien g hier soir sur
la ligne la ligne
3 c'est récent ça c'est l'actualité du
jour
[Musique]
regardez grand on est on est
incroyable cette vidéo alors nous avons
récupéré une seconde vidéo filmé
visiblement cette fois-ci par un des
jeunes en train de chanter le même
groupe de jeunes
regardez 93
[Applaudissements]
ouisou vive le 93 ouais vive la C oua
ouis ou ou ou ou ou ouais
ouais voilà donc c'est ce même groupe de
garçons Manon merci d'être avec nous
merci à vous vraiment c'est c'est fou
d'avoir filmé ça aujourd'hui quand on va
on va revenir sur toute l'histoire mais
quand vous avez filmé vous êtes dit quoi
vous êtes dit c'est je suis je suis dans
un monde de fou vous êtes dit bah
honnêtement je savais pas trop ce qui se
passait je rentrais juste des cours et
bah j'ai vu une bande de jeunes pour moi
il CIT quasiment 20 arrivé dans le métro
comme des sauvage je me suis dit ou là
ils vont cerer le métro et je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce que il
sortent des des propos de la comme ça
quoi enfin c'est super grave pouz
raconter depuis le début donc ce qui se
passe il est quelle heure là il était
18h20 à peu près 18h20 donc vous êtes
dans le métro tranquille et quand vous
les avez vu arriver vous avez vous avez
flippé un peu c'est ça j'ai flippé je me
suis dit mais enfin ils sont quand même
énorme enfin c'est ils sont combien
combient pour moi ils étaient quasiment
une vingtaine je pense ils sont vraiment
arrivés en masse en tapant contre les
vites du métro bah vraiment comme des
sauvages je me suis dit VO là on va se
faire prendre un parti et vraiment je
m'attendais pas ils ont commencé en fait
à à chanter direct oui ils ont commencé
bah déjà à faire énormément de Boucan et
ils ont commencé déjà à insulter donc la
police oui d'accord ils ont ils onté la
police nique la BAC nique la police
mis en boucle en fait d'accord ils ont
aussi insulté la France en lesant nique
la France et cetera mais vive la CAF
c'est ça oui oui oui oui exactement ils
ont dit aussi vive le RSA oua c'est ça
ils ont aussi insulté la communauté LGBT
en disant oui nique la communauté LGBT a
STI contre la police contre la
communauté LGBT contre la France c'est
ça et contre aussi le peuple juif donc
c'est ce moment en fait où j'ai filmé je
savais pas du tout en fait ce qu'ils
allaient dire moi j'ai commencé peur de
filmer ils vous voyaient ou pas du tout
non ils étaient ils étaient vraiment
dans leur truc j'ai quand même essayé de
de de me cacher un peu parce que j'avais
un peu peur qu'on qu'on me prenne mon
téléphone ou qu'on prenne la partie mais
je voulais vraiment que ces proposl soi
euh diffusé entre guillemets pour pour
que les gens voient ce qui s'est passé
dans le métro parce que si j'avais pas
filmé bah personne l'aurait vu et je
trouve ça très très très très grave ce
genre de propos ex non mais c'est c'est
extrêm grave qu'est- qu été la réaction
des des autres passagers dans le métro
euh ils étaient tous scandalisés euh ils
savaient pas trop comment réagir il y a
une dame qui a essayé de de leur dire
non par contre pas les Juifs et ben ils
se sont moqués d'elle ils l'ont envoyé
bouler et et quand ils ont n n que la
France il y a un vieux monsieur qui leur
a dit mais pourquoi vous restez en
France dans ces cas-là si vous insultez
il a dit bah nous on est juste logé en
fait on est logé vive le RSA nique la
France et vive la
donc il étaent une vingtaine vingtaine
de jeunes euh ils sont restés combien de
temps dans le dans le wagon avec vous
j'aurais dit plutôt une dizaine de
minutes ils sont descendus à Opéra
d'accord euh donc ça a duré plusieurs
stations mais c'était vraiment station à
peu près je saurais pas trop trop dire
j'étais vraiment sous le coup sous le
coup cé interminable bah c'est ça
surtout je comprenais pas forcément pas
pensé à sortir du du métro non bah
j'étais j'étais assise et j'ai juste B
je je filmais je me suis dit vaut mieux
que les propos soit quand même
enregistré parce que c'est très très
grave euh c'est c'est c'est incroyable
hein euh oui non mais il y a une
libération de la par l' antisémite qui
est insupportable je sais même pas si on
aurait pu tenir ses propos euh il y a il
y a il y a il y a quelques semaines
encore homophobe tout hein en anance
tout antif plus j'imai qu'on viennent
sur les fit je vous dis à 21h30 on est
vraiment sur les fites ils sont pas sur
de Gilles est-ce que de votre point de
vue quand ils sont entrés dans le métro
ils avaient déjà ce champ ces champ très
violents mais notamment celui contre les
Juifs en tête c'était leur but de
choquer ou c'était plutôt si je puis
dire une bande de jeunes comme ça qui
est entré qui a voulu semer la pagaille
B je pense qu'ils ont juste voulu amuser
la galerie et euh enfin c'était vraiment
pour moi c'était des collégiens et euh
c'était juste pour amuser la galerie
faire les clown se marrer quoi a pas eu
d'agressivité envers aucun passager non
non non c'était juste ils étaient là il
faisaent bouger la rame il taper sur les
sur les les parois du métro c'était
juste pour [__] entre guillemets le
bordel alors Manon certains sont
indignés de vous voir rigoler dans la
dans la vidéo vous voulez faire une mise
au point à ce sujet je crois aussi oui
j'ai déjà essayé de répondre à plusieurs
commentaires euh donc en fait
effectivement donc je ris sur la vidéo
mais c'était vraiment un rire de nerveux
parce que bah je savais pas trop comment
réagir j'étais vraiment scandalisé
c'était totalement inattendu moi je
voulais juste rentrer chez moi là base
j' rentrais des cours j'étais fatiguée
et je m'attendais pas du tout à entendre
bah de tels propos dans le métro donc
c'était vraiment juste j'étais j'étais
j'étais choquée c'était pas du tout un
oui
un rire comme certains peuvent
l'interpréter un rire qui cautionne ses
propos c'est ça ou qui voilà c'est ça
donc j'ai quand même dit en légende de
la vidéo comme quoi je ne cautionnais
absolument pas les propos qui ont été
tenus vous avez compris tout de suite ce
qu'il disait parce qu'on vaevoir la
vidéo et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
compliqué rentendre moi j'ai d
l'entendre plusieurs fois
réécouter palestin ouais ouais palestin
ouais
ouais les
grandmè les grand-mèr on est des nazis
on est
[Musique]
fier alors ils avaient quel âge c'est
jeunes pour moi c'était ça devit des
collégiens je pense parce qu'ilétait
vraiment très très jeune oui vraiment
genre voilà 14 15 ans oui à peu près
alors quand ils sont parce qu'on on se
pose plein de questions et tous les
téléspectateurs pose plein de questions
personne ne s'inposé juste des petites
des personnes qui s'indignent un peu
mais personne ne s'interposé personne
n'a n'a voulu arrêter ça céit tout le
monde était un peu tétanisé non c'est ça
bah il y en a quand même qui ont essayé
bah la la jeune femme et le et le vieux
monsieur mais contre une bande de de bah
de 20 de 20 jeunes on se dit enfin on
sait pas trop ce qu'ils ont sur eux
s'ils ont un couteau si donc on est là
on est un peu enfin ça quand même c'est
compliqué de bah d'un d'intervenir dans
cette situation là vous avez vous avez
décidé de mettre la vidéo tout de suite
sur les réseaux non j'ai quand même
réfléchi j'ai quand même réfléchi puis
je me suis dit que fallait quand même
que ces propos là soient rapportés
rapportés c'est ça que les gens puissent
voir ce qui s'est passé dans le métro
par c'est très très graveè bravo Manon
parce que c'est très important ce que
vous avez fait parce que sans vous on
n'aurait pas vu ça alors que c'était
c'est quelque chose s'est passé hier
soir au alentour de 18h c'est c'est
complètement fou oui Gill la grande
question qu'on se pose dans ces cas-là
c'est on est dans le métro qu'est-ce
qu'on on fait et c'est vrai que je je
vous le dis avec énormément de respect
mais ça ça étonne que personne n'ait
tiré le signal d'alarme soit sorti
prévenir le conducteur pour arrêter la
rame pour pouvoir les interpeller voyez
personne n'a eu attention je dis pas que
je leur ais fait du tout hein mais
personne n'a eu cette idée là de de
d'agir promptement non je pense qu'on
était vraiment tous tous choqués par par
ce qui se passait on réalisait pas
forcément bah l'ampleur de la chose vous
êtes pas dit ça va aller plus loin ils
vont ils vont ils vont s'en prendre à
nous passagers de de la RAM ou bah au
début c'était justement ma crainte quand
ils ont commencé à rentrer dans la RAM
on a l'impression que limite être
soulagé excusez-moi de dire ça mais
limite vous êtes dit bon ils sont venus
faire des des guignoles c'est ça bah au
début je me suis à tout moi ils ont des
barres de fer ils vont rentrer ça va
être comme les émeutes donc j'avoue j'ai
eu un petit peu peur sur le coup mais au
vu des des propos tenu c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas moins grave on va dire B
oui JAC moi je trouve que madis vous
avez un courage parce que on sait que
ces momentslà ça peut al là on les
connaît pas on les voit pas et vous nous
dites que c'est vous nous apprenez que
ce sont des collégien mais ça peut aussi
mal tourner si les gens réagissent donc
je suis pas tellement d'accord avec toi
Gilles je trouve qu'il y a pas de
polémique à avoir là-dessus je trouve
que vous êtes une lanceur d'alerte
lanceuse d'alerte et que alors il faut
signaler qu'il y a la plateforme Faros
c'estàdire que ouai mais c'est c'est
important pour les gens qui veulent pas
forcément sur les réseaux mais mais je
trouve queelle elle elle a du courage de
témoage de le signaler parce que ce sont
des propos qui sont évidemment
inadmissibles qui doivent pas être tenus
c'est pas une question seulement
d'antisémitisme c'est un c'est on a
l'impression d'un grand magma de grand N
qui mais là
justement on en est où Gil Verdes de
l'enquête là-dessus sur ces personnes
alors c'est remonté jusquau on peut les
identifier là part oui c'est remonté
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'État donc
il y a une enquête qui a été déclenché
tout de suite confié au service régional
des transports avec tous les moyens
toutes les vidéos surveillan de toutes
les stations de métro de toutes les
rames je suppose que vous allezêt
solliciter aussi peut-être l'avez-vous
déjà été par la police ils vont tout
faire pour les identif c'est sûr qu's
vont les retrouver très vite hein même
avec leur leur compte insta et cetera
c'est finis vite normalement c'est ce
soir ils sont ils sont des oui mais
alors pourquoi la vidéosurveillance est
importante parce que quand il y a un
phénomène de groupe comme ça c'est qui a
prononcé cette parole là pour pouvoir
les les choper et après éventuellement
les condamner donc c'est très important
là ce soirl ils étaient en cours
d'identification ils n'ont pas encore
été interpellés et il risquent très très
gros Cyril même s'ils sont mineurs parce
que il y a la phrase notamment on est
des nazis et fiers qui pourrai après
être qualifié d'apologie du terrorisme
et qui pourrait valoir 50 de prisons
alors c'est des mineurs se seraient
divisés s'ils étaient condamnés he par
deux pense c'est vraiment qu'ils vont
faire il vont être condamnés ah
là je pense qu'il vont rien faire ils
vont peut-être être convoqués moi je
pense qu'il faut convoquer les parents
du coup pour savoir par que là c'est
même pas l'éducation non là je crois pas
la ce là directement ah non non mais là
l'émotion est nationale ils vont être ah
non non non ok j'attends voir raison
attendons de voir je suis d'accord AC le
Rapp à la loi non mais pens un rappel à
la loi vous ce qui va arriver il vont
dire que c'est des gamins et que cétait
que c'est des gamins qui sont rentrés
dans le métro qu's ont chanté qu'il y en
a un qui a lancé l' suivi des qui
tombent s le coup de la loi quand ils
sont partis Manon s'il vous plaît quand
ils sont partis vous êtes dit quoi ceux
qui rest dans dans le dans la bah
j'essaie de réaliser en fait on s'est
tous regardé on était on était choqué on
essay juste de bah de réaliser ce qui
s'est passé en fait vous avez parlé
entre vous pas du tout même pas pas du
tout personne ne sait parler après de ce
qui venait se passerne non le silence
silence limite soulagé qu'il soit parti
quoi c'est ça exactement tout le monde
était soulagé parce que ça a duré
combien de temps m' dit bonne dizaine de
minutes c'est très long c'est très très
long ils ont chanté tout le long long
oui tout le long et et en criant il y
avait des gens qui rentraient ou qui vou
qui n'osaient plus rentrer il pouv il
pouvait pas il pouvit pas rentrer dans
la rame c'était pas possible ils étaient
vraiment devant les portes en fait ils
étaient vraiment bah dans le métro trop
il c'était vraiment entre les deux
portes donc personne pouvait rentrer
personne pouvait sortir en fait fallait
vraiment sortir par une autre porte ou
rentrer par une autre porte et puis
quand ils sont sortis ils ont failli
bousculer un vieux monsieur aussi ils
sont vraiment sortis bah comme tues
sauvages ils sont descendus à quelle
station à Opéra à Opéra d'accord ce que
vous nous avez dit donc à Opéra ils sont
descendus derrière à Opéra c'est vrai
que c'est c'est complètement fou de voir
ça aujourd'hui c'est vrai que derrière
ils ont pu partir tranquillement c'est
ça qui est oui puis plutôt fier d'eux
visiblement enfin content d'eux euh ça
mais en plus ils ont commenté le TikTok
ils ont commencé mon ils ont commenté
mon TikTok quce qu'ils ont dit euh en
disant ouais c'est nous on est fier euh
enfin et et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
réussi à avoir le le compte TikTok d'un
des d'un des garçons qui a du coup bah
posté le TikTok qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure et euh et vraiment ils avaient
l'air d'être très très fier et je pense
que le pire aussi dedans c'est qu'il y
avait énormément de personnes en fait
qui cautionnai les propos qu'ils ont
tenu en disant oui ils ont Raon c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai qu'on voit des
personnes dans votre vidéo limite
rigoler vraiment et dire ouais c'était
un genre c'était marrant quoi ouais
c'est ça ouais c'est exactement ça c'est
fou ça ce que vous nous dites parce que
vous dites ouais il y avait des gens qui
disaient ouais c'est c'est plutôt ils
ont raison dans ce qu'ils disent c'est
ça donc après bon il y avait des gens
qui venaient qui venaient répondre à
leurs commentaires en en les incendiant
entre guillemets mais moi je sais qu'on
était quand même on a quand même été
jusqu'à me chercher mon insta mon Link
kedine pour m'envoyer des des insultes
oui tu as pas honte de rigoler comme ça
tu es la honte de la France en
minsultant de pauvre Conn et cetera
enfin est-ce qu'il y avait des gens qui
vous ont aussi insulté ou un des groupes
qui vous ont dit pourquoi vous avez
filmé et cetera ou il était plutôt fier
oui il y a il y a quand même un des
garçons donc après avoir dit oh c'est
nous c'est nous c'est nous qui du coup a
fait un commentaire en me disant comme
quoi il m'avait demandé de supprimer la
vidéo chose qu'ils n'ont jamais faite
ils m'ont jamais contacté il m'a dit
qu'il voulait porter plantees pour droit
à l'image et je leur ai dit mais on vous
voit pas justement exprès vous êtes de
dos enfin on vous voit pas c'est juste
toi qui qui a dit oui c'est nous enfin
tu t'es toi-même identifié moi j'ai rien
fait j'ai juste poster les propos j'ai
pas incroyable et et donc ils se sont
prêt à vous il y en a qu'un qui vous a
contacté aucun des autres non juste un
alors sachez qu'il y a déjà il y aurait
déjà des gardes à vu hein ça y est déjà
depuis depuis aujourd'hui concernant ce
petit groupe façon quand ils vont
retrouvver un ils vont tous retrouver
très très vite après comme a dit
géraline on va voir qui va passer vous
allezendre le métro très vite vous êtes
traumatisé quand même par événement
comme ça c'est ça pe j'avoue que je suis
un peu traumatisée parce que je la ligne
3 c'est quand même une ligne de métro où
il y a pas forcément énormément de
problèmes dessus on va dire c'est une
ligne plutôt calme et là le fait de voir
ça débarquer grand groupe honnêtement ça
traumatise un peu donc
ouais c'est sûr c'est c'est extrêmement
traatisant et ça va être un peu
compliqué merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous bah merci à vous merci
beaucoup tout de suite c'est bon je v
sur vite
[Applaudissements]
merci c'est insupportable d'aller sur
les réseaux sociaux moi j'y vais pas du
tout donc vous pouvez continuer à
m'insulter je m'en fous total les
réseaux sociaux j'y vais jamais donc
continue à m'insulter je vois je suis en
hashtag ce soir je vais être encore en
TT mais je m'en fous total hein anoun en
TT j'ai l'habitude je pense que je suis
le mec le plus en TT de France donc
continuez mais vous feriez mieux de
faire une marche tous ensemble je vous
le dis avec un drapeau israélien et un
drapeau palestinien et je pense que ça
fera beaucoup plus avancer le CH que vos
conneries sur les réseaux et les
insultes et les menaces et cetera
d'accord arrêtez de menacer dire arrêtez
de menacer arrêtez de faire les malins
sur les réseaux sociaux arrêtez tout ça
pensez plutôt à une paix durable et
peut-être ici et et ne mélangez pas tout
je vous dis personne les gars et arrêtez
de faire croire que vous connaissez sur
le conflit sur les bouts des doigts et
vous connaissez exactement la situation
la seule chose qu'on veut tous c'est un
État palestinien un état israélien
souverain pour les deux h aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est tout ce que tout le
monde veut h mais quand je vois des
abrutis qui appellent à la destruction
quand je vois mort aux Arabes sur
Twitter ou mort aux Juifs je vous dis
ces gars-là pour moi c'est inadmissible
qu'il sont encore sur les réseaux
sociaux il do avoir leur adresse alleer
les chercher et je peux vous dire moi
ils vont passer 3 jours en cellule ils
vont comprendre ce que c'est je va vous
dire ou peut-être m pas 3 jours 3 mois
parce que c'est beaucoup plus qu'il faut
un mec qui dit mort aux Arabes ou mort
aux Juifs pour moi il prend un an de
tôle ferme voilà je vous le dis c'est
c'est aujourd'hui c'est comme ça donc ça
je ça je veux pas le voir moi sur les
réseaux quand je vais sur les réseaux
tous les matins et que je vois ce genre
de message je vous dis j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de me dire il faut arrêter ces
réseaux de de merde qui font qui ne qui
ne vraiment qui ne diffusent que de la
haine merci en tout cas à vous d'être
avec nous ellisabeth meres vous êtes
gardienne d'un immeuble qui a été tagué
oui euh c'est vous qui avez découvert
les tags non euh moi quand je sortais le
matin mes poubelles comme
d'habitude je vois ça euh
personnellement
j'étais choquée bien sûr vous êtes dit
vous êtes dit quoi tout de suite moi
quand j'ai sorti je je je n'arrivais pas
à bouger c'était même un voisin qui m'a
appelle il me dit t'inquiète je vais
appeler la police parce que je
resté excusez-moi un peu choqué c'est
normal norm je suis portugaise je ne
suis pas ni juif ni quoi que ce soit
c'est ça et et vous êtes regardez comme
vous êtes ému ça oui c'est il y a
beaucoup de familles de confessions
juifs dans votre immeuble ben pas autant
que ça bah dans mon immeuble on a de
tout vous voyez c'est un immeuble ça
fait 23 ans je suis là c'est un immeuble
quand on s'entend tous on fait des fêtes
ensemble on n'a jamais parlé de
politique de quoi que ce soit ni des
religions et on sait chacun on sait ce
qu'on est et franchement euh on est très
très bien
et et et voilà quoi ça voilà comme
Monsieur dit là je suis pour la paix et
bien sûr et est-ce que tous les gens là
qui voient en France là qui voit ce qui
se passe actuellement là madame elle a
dit moi je je je suis pas concerné mais
mais je suis ému et vous avez peur oui
voilà par contre lui ex la France et et
les Français je le dis 85 % des Français
ont peur heinourhi et les Français sont
des gens exceptionnels et je le redis
parce que je le vois moi mon public je
le vois tous les gens qui viennent là t
les soir ils veulent ils veulent pas
d'histoire ils veulent ils veulent être
tranquille c'est les gens qui
travaillent qui font leur truc qui qui
on ils ont déjà eu ils ont déjà eu le
covid ils ont eu ils ont eu les on se
rappelle de la période des gilets jaunes
vous croyez quoi parce que là en ce
moment on ne parle que de çaou donc
forcément tous les autres problèmes ils
sont sous le tapis ouis vous croyez que
les agriculteurs il galèrent pas en ce
moment vous croyez que les familles
elles arrivent à vivre normalement et
qu'elles arrivent à boucler leur fin de
mois et comme je disais la la situation
économique elle a pas changé et il y a
des mecs le 15 du mois et ben ils ont
pas pour nourrir leurs enfants et il y a
Noël qui arrive là il y a des parents
qui va arriver dans dans un mois dans 2
mois qui sont comme ça parce qu'ils
disent je vais pas pouvoir offrir de
cadeaux à mes enfants voilà encore cette
année donc donc là comme
l'actualité c'est
essentiellement ce conflit et ben
forcément on oublie tous les autres
conflitsf on oublie tous les autres
problèmes et aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire qu'il y a des Français qui ont
énormément de problèmes m les autres
conflits on oublie aussi les
autr la Guer partout dans le monde on
parle plus al il y a Lucy qui n'a c'est
pas son vrai prénom elle a pas voulu
venir ce soir mais on l'a eu en audio
écoutez bien son témoignage elle a été
victime de choses très graves tag
insulte et même agression physique à
caractère antisémite elle d'abord sur
les tags abominables qui ont été
inscrits devant sa porte à plusieurs
reprises devant la porte de chez elle
écoutez je me réveille la veille de y
quiip cour je vois marquer mort au Juif
sur ma porte 2 jours après j'enlève mort
au Juif j'essaie de de d'enlever une
deuxième fois j'ai eu un autre tag t
jours après une croix gamée les Juifs
gazés j'étais en état de choc c'est mon
infirmier qui m'a réveillé parce que
j'ai un infirmier qui vient CIN fois par
jour pour des insulines
donc il est venu il m'a dit regardez ce
qui est sur la porte euh et j'ai dit
qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur la porte j'ai vu
j'ai dit ça y est ça va recommencer ça y
est ça va recommencer et je suis tombée
il a essayé de me rattraper je j'ai
perdu
connaissance voilà voilà il y a des gens
qui sont incroyables sur Twitter
regardez Boujard voilà lui ça c'est
voilà parce qu'il y a des gens bien sur
Twitter qui dit Anouna et juif oui alors
je suis musulman oui alors l'humain
n'est-il pas fait de la même chair et du
même sang à méditer voilà c'est message
de Pai mais c'est très rare quand on
voit vous allez entendre ça alors Lucy
elle ici était aussi agressé
physiquement frappé elle se fait cracher
dessus et aujourd'hui elle ne sort plus
de chez elle ça ça se passe en France
vous rendez compte en 2023 bientôt 2024
écoutez bien ce témoignage qui est
effroyable la voisine d'as j'ai fait un
peu de bruit elle est monté elle m'a dit
tu arrêtees de faire du bruit elle m'a
attrapé elle m'a sorti dehors et elle
m'a jeté par terre j'ai un handicap à 80
% elle m'a jeté par par terre elle m'a
tapé j'ai connais la tête contre le
placard j'avais une
bosse j'ai terrible c'est terrible
franchement c'est terrible et et hé làas
elle n'est pas la seule aujourd'hui il y
a des gens qui sont protégés et
heureusement qu' sont protégés mais
parce qu'ils sont juifs vous vous rendez
compte en France il y a des gens qui
sont sous protection il y a des villes
parce queil y a eu C ces ces ces étoiles
de David poché en bleu sur de nombreuses
communes 14e arrondissement de Paris des
communes en Bonlieu parisiennes même en
province et bien la police parfois dit
aux gens vous avez été identifiés ne
sortez pas mais où on est quoi et ils
ont raison faut protéger les gens mais
qu'on en soit là c'est désespérant ce
que vous dites alors pour lui les choses
sont claires si elle est agressée de la
sort c'est uniquement parce qu'elle est
juive et elle a très peur de la suite
écoutez juif en 2023 j'ai peur de que ça
recommence comme la chir mon fils il m'a
dit tu ne sors pas maman si je dois
venir te chercher tu attends que
j'arrive et tu descends je monte moi te
chercher j'ai des visites chez le
cardiologue et tout et infirmiers il mon
pour venir me chercher ils savent que
j'ai peur je descendre toute seule je ne
sors plus toute seule c'est fini à
chaque moment j'ai peur
elle nous dit également qu'elle veut
déménager puisque les agressions les
agresseurs ont proposé une solution à
Lucy pour tout arrêter la conversion oh
F on m'a dit tu veux la tranquillité
alors convertis-toi à l'Islam et là tu
seras tranquille on te fout la paix il
m'ont dit tant que tu auras pas la
conversion and on continuera à te
harceler je veux
déménager mais le problème c'est qu'on
me donne pas de logement ça fait
quelques années que ça tu on me le
promet mais personne ne bouge
personne personne ne veut bouger
personne si vous nous rejoignez à 21h3
le témoignage de Lucy euh n changé son
prénom victime de tag insulte et même
régression physique à caractère
antisémite vous allez voir la suite est
est incroyable après elle n'est pas un
CA désolé hein c'est vrai que les les
Juifs de France ont très très peur tous
enfin moi je je leur j'en parle je parle
à quelques-uns ils changent leur nom sur
les les plateformes genre ubert DG
verou ils enlèvent les mesoua parce
qu'ils sont paniqués il ils ont peur
c'estàd qu'ils ont l'impression d'avoir
une cible dans le dos et ils ont une
peur panique moi je vous dire je je vais
vous dire je pense que les réseaux
sociaux ont une part de responsabilité
immense dans ce qui se passe
actuellement dans l'hystérie pour Mo ils
ont la plus grosse part de
responsabilité je vous le dis et c'est
un fléau les réseaux sociaux sont
devenus un fléau dans ce cas précis et
je le redis arrêtez de menacer sur les
réseaux sociaux arrêtez de je ne veux on
veut plus voir de morts aux arabe de
mort aux Juifs sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est c'est
intolérable alors il faut qu'il fasse
passer une loi pour les réseaux sociaux
le gars qui dit mort aux Arabes et qui
est tranquille derrière son ordinateur
15 il faut des semaines et semaines
pourir qui c'est il faut faire une
demande qui est
extrêmement contraignante pour le
retrouver ce garslà moi je vaux pouvoir
le retrouver en une heure et aller chez
lui aller le chercher chez lui le gars
qui a dit mort aux Arabes ou le gars qui
a dit mort aux Juifs et m'en occuper
directement avec la police je vous le
dis voilà parce que c'est inadmissible
et je vous le dis les réseaux sociaux
c'est eux qui foutent la merde sachez-le
ils sont en train de [__] une merde
monstre
et pourquoi pas faire une journée sur
les réseaux sociaux parce que qui dirige
les réseaux sociaux même en France les
gars on les entend jamais alors ils sont
bien contents ils se gavent hein il
c'est El mus qui ve
r Arab juif la liberté d'expression une
journée il devrait lancer des journées
que des tweets avec des drapeaux
palestiniens israéliens voilà que des
tweets comme ça pourquoi il fait pas une
journée comme ça même sur les réseaux
sociaux pourquoi il lance pas une
journée voilà tous les tweets qui seront
à
caractère antisémite anti antimusulmans
ou des gars qui disent on veut la
destruction d'Israël on veut la
destruction de la Palestine on les
enlève on veut que des tweets avec les
deux drapeaux et des tweets de paix
pourquoi ils font pas une journée de
paix sur les réseaux sociaux ça ça ça ça
ça aura un retentissement voilà ça ils
prennent un jour ils disent voilà bah
vous savez quoi la semaine prochaine et
ben le dimanche c'est où voilà où les
gens ont le plus le temps et ben vous
faites une journée et ben vous savez
quoi on fait la Journée de la Paix sur
Twitter parce que ce qu'on lit sur
Twitter je vous le dis c'est que de la
ha et je vous le dis ça donne des idées
et les gars ils voient des tweets ils
voient des trucs qui sont passés ils
disent bah tiens ça nous donne des idées
pour faire des choses ça c'est pas
possible ne croyez pas le gars qui est
venu devant le devant le devant le
studio c'est un gars qui a lu des trucs
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que tout
est déformé tout est on sait même pas
moi j'ai j'ai lu des articles qui
disaient boycotte tes PMP a par parce
qu'on a parce qu'on a boycotte tes PMP
parce qu'on a condamné l'attentat
terroriste du 7 non mais les gars non
mais on est est où là on marche sur la
non parce que les gens disent qu'on
condamne pas les bombardements à Gaza
mais bien les a toujours condamné les
bombardements donc les gens nous les
gens nous disent oui mais vous avez fait
le 7 octobre tout un cinéma mais
maintenant il y a Gaza
c'est c'est les mots qu'on parce que les
gens pensent que c'est la France qui va
régler le problème moi ce que je pense
vraiment la France elle peut rien
faire oui aussi mais il pens que CP qui
va régler problème c'est pas TPMP c'est
pas la France la France peut rien faire
elle va pas y aller toute seule elle
peut rien faire et les mecs te disent
vous avez fait le 7 octobre mais on on
on condamne aussi ce qui se passe en ce
moment on a demandé des c le feu on
condamne ce qui se passe à Gaza faut
faut être nul pour frensa toutes les
idées que j'ai dit là le ministre du
numérique j'aimerais bien l'appeler bah
qu'il le fasse ça cette Journée de la
Paix sur Twitter il trouve un accord
avec Twitter je peux vous dire avec
l'oseille qui prenne Twitter et insta et
cetera je peux vous dire il faut que les
ministres il les mettent au pas je vous
le dis parce que je sais même pas où il
payent des impôts C d'ailleurs sans
doute pas en
France le pouvoir le pouvoir n'est pas
du côté du ministre pour le M donc il
faut renverser tout ça il faut qu'il ait
des leviers et qu'il agisse les leviers
c'est l'oseille he crois-moi le levier
c'est toujours l'oseille C sur avec des
gens comme ça je te le dis bah il faut
taper au portefeuille et quand tu vas
leur dire on va vous mettre une taxe à
Twitter ou insta qui va les mettre KO tu
vas voir s'ils vont pas le faire ça je
te le dis parce qu'à un moment il faut
arrêter d'être gentil aussi avec ces
gars-là à un moment ça suffit et ce qui
est insupportable c'est la passivité
c'est le fait que personne ne réagisse
toi tu appelles à une journée de de paix
une une marche pour la paix c'est des
choses qu'on a déjà vu en
France GS avece PAL dans mais à tous les
niveaux à tous les niveaux il y a plein
d'initiatives qui pourraient être faites
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est terrifiant
ce bégement de l'histoire et cette
passivité le fait que rien que personne
ne dise rien c'est encore plus important
pour moi la Journée de la Paix sur
Twitter que même dans la rue je vous le
dis ça c'est un c'est Twitter mer vous
savez bien que l'algorithme de Twitter
n'e n'aime que le clash et c'est pour ça
c'est tant qu'on aura pasant qu'onura
pas en profondeur modif j une journé
avec prent pour une journée M derè tu
peux empêcher un mec dans son salon
d'être un soldat israélien ou un soldat
palestinien avec son iPhone 15 tu peux
pas l'empêcher il veut faire des
révolutions dans son salon en
pantoufle par contre la marche là c'est
très intelligent et c'est
mieux je souviens vous dit que c'éta
impossible Mo j'aimerais bien que les
gens qui font
ça regardent des vra documentaire sur la
Choa et qui prennent des cours
d'histoire qui se rendent compte de ce
que ça a été les 6 millions de Juifs qui
sont morts dans des camps de
concentration j'ai une proposition à
faire rmon j'ai une proposition à faire
j'ai une proposition à faire j'ai une
proposition à faire au service public je
leur demande de diffuser tous les films
de Rotman de rediffuser le pianiste de
rediffuser tous les grands films et tous
les grands documentaires qui apprendront
aux jeunes ce qu'a été la Choa et
comment a été la montée de
l'antisémitisme et ce que
l'antisémitisme du 19e siècle a fini par
donner au début du 20e et
ensuite et ensuite avec la bonté du tout
ça important il y a y a un problème dans
ce pays c'est que je pense que je pense
que les gens qui font ça ne savent pas
ce qu'ils font je suis d'accordc on on a
reçu la dernière fois un professeur ici
qui dit lui-même que les professeurs
sont obligés de se restreindre de ne pas
apprendre on va pas rentrer làdans oui
mais pas d'endre la choix dans
lu qui nous dit que plusucinant dans
l'affaire dansaire Luc qui veut
déménager qui voilà qui qui qui qui qui
vit des moment incroyable la pauvre
victime tag insulte même agression
physique à caractère antisémite elle dit
que malgré les preuves et les émements
concrets la police ne peut apparemment
rien
faire la police ne veul pas prendre les
plaintes de voisinage ils m'ont coupé il
y a une semaine deux fois le fil
d'Internet j'ai été il m'ont dit on peut
pas c'est du voisinage on sait pas c'est
qui donc tant que c'est du voisinage on
peux rien faire rien du tout je suis
fatiguée je peux plus je suis en
dépression je peux plus j'arrive plus ce
que je demande c'est un appel au secours
c'est tout qu'on m'aide à sortir d'ici
je peux plus
elle envoie un message à faire passer au
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron écoutez il puisse nous protéger
surtout nous donner une sécurité parce
qu'on a aucune sécurité aucune parce que
tout simplement on est juif et le mot
juif ne leur convient pas on se fait
agresser il vient et c'est tout sans
plus les gens n'ont rien du tout
derrière voilà merci à Lucy pour son
témoignage merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous merci à
vous un couple de moldav a été
interpellé pour avoir dessiné 15 étoiles
à lettre de pochoir dans le 10è
arrondissement de Paris Gille où on en
est alors alors ils ont été reconnus par
un Riverin ils ont été interpellés ce
sont des moldaves donc de 33 et et 29
ans
alors ils ont dit d'abord que quelqu'un
leur aurait demandé de faire ça et
europin a révélé donc il y avait un
commanditaire de nationalité russe
maintenant reste à savoir qui est cet
homme et quelle était la motivation
alors justement on ne sait pas encore
maintenant si c AG on pour but
d'insulter le peuple juif ou d'en
revendiquer l'appartenance notamment
puisqu'il s'agit de l'étoile bleue et
non jaune il est nécessaire d'enquêter
donc au regard du contexte géopolitique
et à son retentissement au sein de la
population dit le parqu exactement c'est
le parquet qui s'interroge il peut y
avoir deux théories la troisième étant
puisque ça vient de Russie est-ce que ce
ne serait pas une volonté de
déstabiliser un peu plus la France qui
est en ce moment dans une situation
complexe donc on se pose toutes les
questions et Cyril le mystère perdure
parce qu'on a pas encore arrêté les
autres auteurs ce couple là a été
interpellé pour CAG mais il y a tous les
autres notamment les étoiles jaunes et
cetera et là la police traque ceux qui
ont tagué sur les murs d'autres villes
ce ne serait pas eux voilà il y aurait
un autre groupe parce qu'il y a
Saint-Ouin par exemple exactement
Saint-Ouin aubertvillier mais oui
exactement et en province il y a eu
aussi alors est-ce qu'il y a des gens
comme ça disparates est-ce qu'il y a un
autre group à Lyon exactement voilà donc
est-ce qu'il y a un autre groupe en tout
cas au moins en région parisienne les
policiers s'interroge et le pense sans
en être sûr euh encore voilà d'accord
mais est-ce qu'on donc on sait pas
maintenant si ce sont des actes ou des
actes absolument pas et le fait que ce
soit bleu le parquet c'est pas moi le
parquet s'interroge comme c'est bleu
est-ce que
voilà si c'était jaune on a pas de doute
comme c'est bleu est-ce que ce ne serait
pas une volonté voilà d'appartenance à
Israël plutôt que des tags antisémites
d'autant que les étoiles bleues n'ont
pas forcément été mis dans des
habitations où étai des Juifs voilà donc
il a une grosse interrogation du parquet
bah écoutez c'est ce serait ce serait
plutôt une bonne nouvelle ah oui ce
serait ce serait moins pire moi je tiens
quand même à dire un petit truc parce
que c'est vrai que là aussi on peut le
dire Gill il y a eu il y a eu beaucoup
de gens qui ont dit oui c'est c'est des
personnes de confession
musulmanes qui leur sont tombés dessus
et cetera on voit exactement donc
attention attention les Chéries
attention aux fausses informations il
sont très vite relayés sur les réseaux
et qui font beaucoup de mal derrière
attention à ça je vous le dis il y a eu
un mouvement de panique une
stigmatisation alors que on voit pour
l'instant T cas le premier groupe qui a
été appréhendé ça n'a rien à voir avec
ça et ça en ce moment il y a une
hystérie générale donc dès qu'il y a un
truc ça devient n'importe quoi donc il
faut un petit peu se calmer et vous
voyez peut-être que ça c'est pas du tout
ce qu' vous croyez donc voilà donc on
espère que voilà en tout cas qu'il vont
trouver les autres personnes oui Val en
même temps effectivement ça interroge
cette histoire de de commanditaire
russse souvenez-vous ce que disait Gill
kpel ici qui disait qu'il y avait tout
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait une sorte
d'embrasement mondial avec des des
puissances étrangères qui viennent
déstabiliser les pays de démocratiques
dont la Russie dont on dit qu'elle est
aussi à la manœuvre pour essayer de
mettre un peu le bazar partout parce que
on détournerait le regard de l' et
cetera donc c'est voilà OK et juste pour
préciser ch les moldav vont être
expulsés ils seront pas
jugés régulre jeis je voudrais vous
raconter une très belle histoire à 20h32
on est en direct le témoignage de ce
chauffeur de taxi dans la ville de Raat
c'est le fièvre de la communauté béouine
en Israël Youssef ziadne a sauvé à lui
seul une trentaine de participants à la
rêve parti où le Hamas a fait 260
victimes il dit certains con que
certains s'étonnent que j'ai risquer ma
peau pour sauver des vies juives je n'ai
fait que mon devoir c'est un Arabe
israélien je n'ai fait que mon devoir en
sauvant des êtres humains qui comptaient
sur moi peu importe leur religion Israël
est mon pays et ils sont mes concitoyens
magnque il raconte ce matin du du 7
octobre où il est arrivé à la rêve
partie j'ai déposer des clients au
festival la veille je devais venir les
récupérer le lendemain à midi mais à 7h
du matin j'ai reçu un appel paniqué de
leur part des terroristes attaquer les
environs il me suppliit de venir les
chercher j'ai foncé à leur rencontre laa
puuie dequ quête qui s'abat sur le
pourtour de la bande de Gaza ne suffit
pas à le dissuader pas plus que les
coups de feu retendissants au aux
alentours Youssef ziadne accède aux
abords de la rêve partie rempl son van
d'une trentaine de jeunes féards apurés
pour certains gèvement blessés et met le
pied au plancher une histoire incroyable
et ça c'est un héros ça pour moi pour
tous ceux qui disent sur les réseaux que
la paix n'est pas possible que que que
voilà tout ça ça ça c'est le meilleur
combat contre ce qui se passe
actuellement sur les réseaux sociaux et
bravo à lui c'est vraiment un héros pour
moi c'est le héros bravo à
[Musique]
lu